alan fontaine président de l'association
française des maîtres restaurateurs et
michel fize sociologue auteur du livre
de la bima à l'espoir
bonjour messieurs merci hâte que d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france michel
fize quel est le profil de ces
manifestants qui se mobilisent donc pour
la sixième semaine consécutive
eh bien je crois c'est un profil qui
vient compléter celui des gilet jaune
nous avions avec les gilet jaune plutôt
des catégories populaires voire un
certain nombre de couches moyennes nous
avons avec les antilles passe des
personnes dont on sait par certaines
études qu'elles sont un peu plus
diplômées et qu'elles représentent
d'autres catégories professionnelles
donc encore une fois je crois qu'on
assiste à un élargissement sociale des
manifestants à l'occasion de ces défilés
maintenant hebdomadaire
alors fontaine vous êtes tenus depuis le
9 août à contrôler les passes annie
terre à l'entrée de vos établissements
quel retour est ce que vous avez
des collègues qui vous qui sont avec
vous au sein de l'association des
maîtres restaurateurs
côté les retours ont réservé avant
également il y avait une profonde
angoisse nous profonde inquiétude pour
mettre cela en place puisque évidemment
ou qu'un restaurateur une été pour le
pass à lithaire en tombe bien on nous a
fermé le 14 mars 2020 ou le 29 octobre
2000 vague jour au lendemain on a fait
du stop and go depuis maintenant dix
neuf mois on est rentré dans des
mémoires et donc on n'est jamais
d'accord avec tout ce qui nous arrive
depuis le début alors il y avait
beaucoup d'angoissé elle beaucoup dans
le mot d'envoi surtout sur les
répercussions par son client car
forcément le prestataire c'est très dur
a à faire psychologiquement l'outil est
très simple il n'y a pas de souci tout
le monde sait se servir de l'alcool mais
le fait de demander quelque chose à
quelqu'un est compliqué surtout pour
nous qui sommes des marchands de
convivialité de bonne heure et d'accueil
r quand on avait des envies en fait
alors les clients dans la grande
majorité des quelques cas de gym verbale
et un ou deux cas de joutes physiques
malheureusement à déplorer mais dans la
grande majorité joue le jeu arrive avec
le passé et terre
depuis le début de la semaine beaucoup
dont on n'a pas de refus la semaine
d'avant c'était la semaine pédagogique
est donc évidemment il ya eu des gens
qui sont venus s'en passer et terre mais
qui ont été dans la majorité des cas
accepter leurs exceptions on le reste
combien comment ça se passait ils
n'accordent pas compris comment ça
fonctionne elle est donc tout ça s'est
plutôt bien passé la semaine dernière
après vous avez des restaurateurs il
faut les saluer parce qu'il faut pas les
stigmatiser qui ont le courage qui
encouragent de ne pas vouloir et prendre
ce pass inter le faire et donc s'opposer
à la loi et en même temps être peut-être
sous des contraintes financières d'abord
aidé à mort et après peut-être l'absence
de fonds de solidarité donc ils ont
courage d'avoir faire ça je pense qu'il
faut non pas
nous
solidaires et ne pas les condamner
surtout ne pas les condamner parce que
c'est un grand courage qu'ils ont ils
sont à peu près 80 en france à dire non
à ceux face à l'inter et il faut leur
dire que c'est des gens c'est les chefs
d'établissement et femmes et des hommes
responsables ils ont pris cette
responsabilité là et il faut reconnaître
cela et surtout pas les stigmatiser
parce que nous sommes tous ensemble mais
nous sommes avant tout des citoyens et
en tant que chef d'entreprise certains
ont pris une responsabilité de citoyen
qu'il faut reconnaître et surtout pas
stigmatiser le passé ni terre qui
continue donc de mobiliser contre lui
michel fize que vous compreniez que ce
mouvement de contestation perdure en
plein été
je n'ai pas entendu la question est ce
que vous comprenez comment est ce que
vous expliquez que ce mouvement de
contestation contre le poste sanitaire
dur en plein coeur de l'été
d'un côté il faut définir peut-être ce
que ces manifestations désigne ces
manifestations c'est aujourd'hui
clairement l'expression d'une
insurrection
hebdomadaire permanente ou quasi
permanente depuis novembre 2018 je crois
que d'une manière générale les français
sont fatigués excédé désorientés
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
inquiets pour leur présent ils sont
inquiets pour pour l'heure à leur avenir
donc ils sont déterminés je crois à se
débarrasser de ce qui à leurs yeux
représente une entrave une entrave
majeure l'entravent majeur c'est un
pouvoir qu'ils estiment arrogant
personnel qui décide de tout tout le
temps partout pour tous sans
considération ni des lieux-dits des
territoires ni d'idées profession vous
savez il suffit de regarder les
pancartes gens regardaient une tout à
l'heure il y avait ce slogan reprend on
passe macron dégage c'est le même slogan
qui lie à 2018 on est dans une logique
du dégagisme poli
et nous avons perdu la connexion avec
michelle sison va tenter de le retrouver
ces prochaines minutes alain fontaine
vous évoquez tout à l'heure c'est ce
sentiment de stigmatisation de la parole
vis-à-vis d'une serre d'une partie de
dés des restaurateurs est ce que vous
vous évoquez là ses propos tenus par le
ministre de l'économie il ya quelques
jours il n'y aura pas d' aide pour les
restaurateurs qui ne jouent pas le jeu
c'est le contribuable qui finance le
fonds de solidarité alors je ne vois pas
comment expliquer aux contribuables
qu'il va financer des gens qui trichent
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
ses propos de bruno le maire
veut non bruno le maire c'est des propos
qui sont tout à fait normaux parce qu'il
s'est battu avec les syndicats la ans
hommes se sont battus pour arriver à
sauver à peu près et 40 je dis bien chez
40% de la restauration française est
aujourd'hui la restauration française et
de ou grâce au fonds de solidarité grâce
à l'activité partielle et tout cela donc
ils se sont un peu floués par rapport à
cette opposition pas solitaire mais cela
dit autant je peux comprendre ces
paroles autant le ministre doit
comprendre aussi que des citoyens qui
sont effectivement
on dire il remercie ce qui a été fait
pour pour la restauration mais c'est
aussi des citoyens et il doit isoler une
réaction par rapport à ce passe
solitaire dont ils savent quand il dit
ça monsieur le maire il prévient il
prévient et donc les gens qui sont en
face sont assez responsables pour savoir
ce que ce qui leur en coûtera 1000 en
aucun cas quand je dis il faut pas les
stigmates c'est au pas les stigmatiser
c'est une c'est une expression naturelle
de la démocratie qu'on va pas on va
remettre ça en doute quand même ils ont
droit de contester mais par contre
effectivement monsieur le maire après à
préciser les choses en contestant et
effectivement ils se mettre en ordre
c'est toi qui a été qu'ils étaient les
mises en a qui a été mise en place et
bien sûr il encore le fait de plus avoir
le fonds de solidarité mais ils le
savent il a prévenu maintenant on peut
pas reprocher à monsieur le maire de
l'état peut pas vexé mais un peu flou et
par rapport à tout le travail qui a été
fait avec monsieur le maire alain griset
et les syndicats on a été je crois
l'activité de restauration dans le monde
l'appli défendu la plus soutenue donc
aujourd'hui effectivement il a un
sentiment de entre guillemets de
vexations mais en même temps il faut que
lui comprenne qu'il y a des citoyens
derrière les chefs d'entreprise et qu'un
citoyen il est monté sur des
fondamentaux de démocratie et des fois
il peut se révolter même contre quelque
chose qui paraît évident à la majorité
des restaurateurs mais acceptons pour
neil une minorité de restaurateurs qui
soit contre se passe à lithaire accepte
aulas vous parlais tout à l'heure michel
fize de cette défiance à l'égard des
macron aujourd'hui le chef de l'état
représente le dénominateur commun de
tous les manifestants qui on vous le
rappeliez a un profil très hétéroclite
oui et je dirais presque à peu près
depuis son élection enfin soyons un peu
indulgents depuis en tout cas novembre
2018 ou une partie des slogans étaient
déjà tournés contre contre sa présence
contre sa présence à l'elysée je crois
qu'il faut avoir conscience que
maintenant les français aspirent à deux
objectifs retrouver une pleine liberté
notamment celle d'aligner devenir de
faire les choix que que l'on veut dans
une démocratie bien comprise et aussi
deuxième objectif qui est un peu perdu
de vue avec eux sanitaire c'est
retrouver une pleine sécurité économique
et là je peux vous dire sans me tromper
beaucoup que les manifestations vont
décidément la laison allah n'est pas
très bonne avec michel fize merci à tous
les deux messieurs d'avoir participé à
cet échange michel fize sociologue alain
fontaine un président de l'association
française de maître restaurateur